here we are and we're watching sponsor
after sponsor after sponsor pull out we
heard virgin america Virgin Airlines
America pulled their sponsorship we
heard carmax and the names just keep
floating in you can see a state farm
insurance Red Bull all as of 330 this
afternoon saying enough we don't want to
be associated with the Clippers as a
result of sterling it what's going to
happen to the team what's going to
happen to the team is the team is going
to stay in Los Angeles and it's going to
be the Clippers but not the old Clippers
who didn't win anything and nobody paid
attention to which is part of this story
but the new Clippers who are in the
playoffs and now there's talk of Magic
Johnson buying the team there's a lot by
the way I have a feeling that this team
is getting cheaper and cheaper by the
minute as all these sponsors pulls out
so at Magic could get out quite a deal
he could but not Magic Johnson seems to
know what deals to get and who's who but
really what you're seeing I think is a
typical pattern that we've seen
certainly in the Internet era in the
social media era where you do have to be
careful and you know Andy it also shows
us sort of how business can really
influence some social change and you
know it's clear that you know businesses
don't want to be associated with
anything like this I mean you you've
been a president of business operations
there for the Memphis Grizzlies how do
you see this playing out Trish this is
now a global issue when the President of
the United States does a press
conference in Malaysia and mentions adam
silver in the NBA this is no longer a
black white issue this is a green issue
and as the NBA looks to expand its brand
it's a yellow issue it's a brown issue
there a global brand companies are
voting with their pocketbooks and moving
away from what the reprehensible thought
pattern was of Donald sterling the
positive is that by tomorrow night's
game in LA adam silver and the NBA The
Players Association the sponsor
community and all those people in the
NBA community have to get together and
make a very strong statement
away from what Donald sterling has
represented Mason lemons in one of your
sources telling you what are you hearing
is actually going to happen well it's
gonna have to be a strong statement
obviously everybody is gonna is watching
this at this point but he's he's really
had such a small amount of time to
figure this out the silvers probably
been huddled with lawyers and there's a
lot of legal implications that he's
dealing with by the way this is a guy
who's new to the job I mean and this
might actually wind up really being his
defining moment how does he as the new
Commissioner of the NBA handled this
well he's following David Stern who was
in this for 30 years have probably never
had a similar crisis where he's dealing
with not only the fans but the players
there's outrage on all sides Stern had
some other issues and big crises but not
quite like this so if he's following
stearns path stern did have a pretty
good record of diversity but honestly
Donald Sterling's been around for a
while and there are a lot of stories and
reports and lawsuit settlements about
this so that's one of the questions he
has dance Andy what do you think Adam
Silver should do right now I think you
should firewall Donald sterling from any
opportunity to be involved in NBA
business and Trish let's not lose sight
of the fact that there have been so many
flashpoints in sports over the last few
months whether you know it's jason
collins whether it's the circumstance of
bullying in the end in the NFL and the
world focuses on it for a short period
of time this one is different this goes
to the DNA of basketball the DNA of
people getting together and Adam needs
to act strongly swiftly no matter what
is legal adviser for many reasons but
you know obviously if you're one of the
players on the court you want to know
that the NBA is standing behind you
there and behind what's right